c'est clair de toute façon je lâcherai
jamais c'est mon sang qu'on m'a arraché
donc des années là je vais reprendre une
chaîne pour que qu'il ait
une femme quand il revient on sait qu'il
va revenir
ouais je vais retrouver de façon je vais
le retrouver à part si c'est dur lui
fait du mal malheureusement les
policiers estiment avoir autre chose à
faire que de tenter de retrouver un
chien de manière très aléatoire c'est
honteux je pense pas du tout la défense
c'est honteux mais voilà la raison il y
a des moments je suis terrorisé il y a
des moments je suis rempli d'espoir et
là j'ai mon téléphone qui sonne j'ai
envie de décrocher parce que j'ai
peur que ça soit quelqu'un qui me dise
qu'il est avec lui quoi
je vous entends